foreign
[Applause]
campaigning is already underway less
than 24 hours after Boris Johnson's
shocked resignation as an MP
labor MPS and activists descended on his
old Uxbridge and South ruislip
constituency this is Danny Beale the
labor candidate and began knocking on
doors I think it's clear that Rishi
sunak has lost control of his party he
is simply too weak to unite The Divided
Tories who are more interested in
tearing alongside of each other causing
their own prime minister by-election
difficulties the cost of a by-election
rather than focusing on the issues that
actually matter to voters here in
Uxbridge and also all over the country
morning opponents are accusing Mr
Johnson of running away after he quit
condemning the Privileges committee
inquiry into claims that he knowingly
lied to Parliament as a whitewash and
Kangaroo Court
but as pressure mounts on Rishi sunak
who now faces three by-elections
ministers insist they're not downbeat
I'm not going to second guess why the
former prime minister took the decision
when he took that decision I haven't
seen the Privileges committee report
indeed very few people have his decision
was purely a matter for him our focus is
not on that our focus is on delivering
for this country that's where Rishi
sunax mindset is former cabinet
ministers claim it's time to move on
from the Johnson sunac drama the sooner
they can put this behind them the sooner
is clear that Boris Johnson is is
finished that there isn't a large body
of support within the Parliamentary
party for him the sooner the
conservative party can move on from this
soap opera and the better their chances
at the next general election I'm going
now so there's no point hugging around
today but Johnson airliner Dean Doris
has also quit triggering a by-election
in her mid-bed bedfordshire constituency
and Nigel Adams has become the latest
Johnson supporter to quit immediately
meaning a by-election two in his Selby
and Einstein constituency in North
Yorkshire
the Tories give every impression of
being totally unprepared for the trio of
resignations which have handed labor the
opportunity to inflict further damage on
Mr sunac John Craig Sky News Uxbridge